auch bis repetita dix ans après les
parisiens ont à nouveau battu les
nantais en finale de la coupe de france
de foot bal hier soir au parc les
canaris ont bu la coupe jusqu'à la lie
thierry clopeau 49e minute le début de
la descente aux enfers pour le fc nantes
faute discutable ici de christian
karembeu sur laurent fournier qui en
rajoute un peu l' arbitre monsieur harel
siffle penalty karembeu dijon et c'est
la première expulsion
le penalty est transformé par antoine
kombouaré la joie du néo calédonien dans
les vestiaires la tristesse de 40 mois
le traumatiser ce péno et ils ont su
tirer profit en grande fois ils ont
gagné que par ça donc c'est moi qui la
donne c'est qu'on puisse el makina
donnons parisien en l'espace de dix
minutes le psg va tuer cette finale
petite faute de makelele sur bravo faute
qui porte à conséquence superbe coup
franc de ginola une belle balle brossée
qui trompe
david marraud 2 0 pour le psg le sénat
est à l'agonie et ce n'est pas fini 59e
minute corner et coup de tête d'alain
roche c'est la correction les jeunes
nantais sont ko debout
monsieur arrive ensuite jouer du sifflet
du carton 71e minute expulsion de vous
lire
pour cette faute sur ginola dix minutes
plus tard carton rouge cette fois ci
pour lima hauteur il est vrai d'un
vilain tacle le fc nantes va jouer la
fin de la rencontre à 8 contre 11 il n'y
a plus de match le psg l'emportent
finalement 3-0 3e coupe de france qu'on
le club parisien qui fêtait ses 20 ans
d'existence belle récompense après une
super saison 93
mais c'est vrai qu'il nous manquait
quelque chose et on a fini seconds toute
la saison mais pas finir second en coupe
de france donc gagner ce soir c'est je
dis pas que sam wagne les choses parce
qu'il est normal dans le football dans
la vie mais bon c'est un truc de fouace
et c'est quelque chose qu'on voulait
vraiment elle pour financer en beauté
pour finir sur un petit peu un coup de
chapeau
et pourquoi d'iveco bornes paris saint
germain a fait un très bon parcours
cette saison
psg nantes une finale qui à cause de
cette cascade de carton rouge ne restera
sans doute pas dans les annales
consolation pour les nantais l'an
prochain durant la coupe de l'uefa et
les parisiens la coupe des coupes